Second
category.
Okay,
we are live.
Hello,
we've got some stuff to do today. Um,
we're going to start by checking on the
experiments from last night. We have at
least one result that it seems quite
promising.
I don't want to get stuck refactoring
all day. I think we're going to have
some fun. We're going to do some of like
the little potential research
improvements today. Some of the easy
stuff. It's a Friday.
See if we can bank some easy wins.
And we're going to start thinking about
the main experiments for next week.
Jump over to stream view.
What's puffing? Eh, how's it going?
Okay, so this is the result.
from overnight
in 2400 seconds which is 40 minutes.
Uh this is the exact same hardware that
I ran the previous sweep on.
Go to constellation. Here
we have all of our Puffer 4 experiments,
all our baselines. And you'll notice
around that same time we only had 1300
uh 13,000 score before and the best
score that we'd ever obtained on 2048
is 14,300.
This
is 2400 points higher and in less time.
That seems pretty good to me. That seems
pretty good.
Um, I think it would be
it would be pretty surprising, I would
think, if this is not a clear cut win.
Thank you, Elliot.
We're going to pull these results. Uh,
we're going to look at them.
Oops. Let's just uh get rid of stuff
that we don't need.
and inferno.
One, two, three, four, five, depending
on this one. Four or five good tasks is
fine. We may or may not want this one,
right? This one honestly doesn't matter.
We Let's just take this off the list.
[ __ ] this. We don't need to give
ourselves one more thing to do to please
academics.
So, we have ablations to run. We've got
nice four test environments.
And we have a few easy chill things that
we can play with today.
Let's start with our experimental
analysis. I am going to close this
We don't mess with it.
Um, let's just do
zip dash r48
logs g48 star.
Okay.
and I believe we have our old log
somewhere.
Let's just look at these alone first.
Okay.
Uh ooh
might not be super great actually.
Hm.
Let us just let me compare something
real quick just roughly and then we'll
get it on the same axis.
Thus the axes are different. The axes
might be different.
Let me see.
Okay, so we have log scale uptime
linear scale PF.
So 34.
Yeah. Yeah, the axes are different. Hang
on. I think we're fine
That's one lucky point. H
I think we need to get these on the same
axis, honestly.
any preview?
Uh, so the task that we got this
original result on was a super sparse
maze.
You have a 1 in 10 million chance or
randomly generated sparse mazes I should
say where you have a 1 in 10 million
chance of getting a reward.
Any reasonable baseline that you can
write will get zero score on this. Uh,
puffer gets up to 90% sulfate.
Okay. So, our best results are with
curriculum here about five
with a very high prioritization
coefficient.
Little suspect actually,
and a high correction factor,
interestingly enough.
State buffer size.
Uh, state buffer size appears, it
appears this matters, but it caps out at
the 8k.
That's interesting.
And I think those are all the curriculum
params that we care about. Let's get
these onto the same axis real quick.
Yeah, pretty much. Um,
would this solve Montazuma's revenge?
It might solve Montazuma's revenge.
Uh, the reason I don't care about that
task is because the sim is so slow.
Like, we don't bother with tasks that
are just super slow to simulate.
And uh the method that this is based off
of that did apply on Montazuma's
revenge, they used heruristics,
Okay, let's get this on to the same the
same spot.
I forgot to check the exploration decay,
didn't I?
Okay, it's actually quite low.
Interesting. eight. But it does matter.
This param matters.
We do minus one. Whoops.
One, two, three, four, five.
And this goes to 25.
Uh this also implies that our sweeping
algorithm is messed up
because
these points are in the space of this.
Yeah, our sweeping algorithm is messed
up.
I think we just go make some basic
changes
and um we wait for protein fixes to
rerun this.
So this is soda up here and this is the
previous best. But then the shape of
these runs is very odd.
This should not be able to happen. This
basically implies that the hyperprem
sweep is kind of having a difficulty
keeping up with this number of search
terms.
Okay.
No, we still get the result. I'm still
I'm not displeased with this.
Let's do Hang on. First of all, I have
this other terminal up on my side here.
Um, let me just make sure that this is
going.
I'm going to need this machine back
soon.
Uh,
yeah, I'm going to need this machine
back soon.
In fact, I kind of want this machine
back now.
I'm going to just I'm going to kill this
run.
We'll do the client crap later, maybe.
Oh, this is this is up to date,
right?
Yeah, we're up to date here.
Oh, wrong wrong machine.
Okay, I'm going to do this and then I'm
going to while this does that, I'm going
to actually make sure I know the uh
correct implementation of this
Okay, this is good. Where was the warm
up
momentum warm-up?
So this is
November 6, 2024.
steps equals okay
value residual embed shortcut and then
momentum warm-up is this little thing
here.
value with residual with learnable
lambda.
see, the thing is that language modeling
bros have such a more consistent task
that they can do stuff like this.
Hey Jess, we're doing a couple like
chill little research things based off
of the Nano GPT speedrun
and then we will uh we'll see what we do
from here.
results from last night are I think
decent.
We have it. Um
let's see. Can I show them real quick? I
think we're going to need to make some
improvements to the uh to protein,
honestly.
Because we're sort of hitting the wall
with how many hypers we can tune.
So, here are the results. We do get
soda. We get soda by quite a lot, but
like the curves are overlapping in this
weird way, right?
It implemented warm-up momentum from
zero. Nice [ __ ] job.
Have the embedding to 64.
That's just pure speed.
Um doing a a few like chill things based
on the nano GPT speedrun first
to see if we get any easy performance
wins and then um
I'm probably starting some heavier
experiments or maybe modifications to
protein.
Love trying to build stuff. Stupid
thing.
Um, yeah, but how do I how do I address
that, dude?
Yeah, this is actually a very small
very small thing it seems.
Did you publish?
No. You know, I really decided that
there wasn't anything reasonable for me
to write about the topic. Um
because the thing is there really isn't
any like interesting substance to write
and the only thing I'm going to do is
give ammunition to idiots that want an
excuse to not think
cuz like the TLDDR is I use some tools.
I try not to over rely on said tools. I
keep trying to think myself. Thank you
very much. um
that like there's not actual substance
to the topic frankly.
See, but the thing is like I'm not
switching models cuz I think one is like
materially better than the other or
anything. I literally just got sick of
feed I gave I got sick of feeding
anthropic money. That's literally it.
It's not that deep.
Hey, we'll try this. Apparently, I don't
think Muan needs warmup.
We'll try a couple other small things,
though.
All this stuff here is like high
likelihood throwaway for reference.
So basically everything past this point
is super minor.
dreams with Jim.
Oh, the gym is in Maryland. I'm in Palo
Alto for the summer.
I did not say that these streams would
be from the gym.
And I missed one run this morning
because I hurt my back deadlifting
yesterday. It's getting better, but um
it needs a day to heal.
Like I could barely walk at all
yesterday.
Yeah, I've been running um I've been
running 10K
um well, Monday through Thursday I did.
I also did one on Sunday.
I'm going to be running again this
Sunday and then next week. I missed one
uh one run today because of back injury.
I think I probably will do some lifting
still. I think I should be good to do
that depending on what I do later today.
I can definitely at least bench.
And then the streams are right here,
right? The streams have been every day.
You know, the deadlifting was dumb. It
was literally just really really shitty
deadlift form because I was so tired
from the run cuz that's like four days
of running in a row on a very aggressive
cut. Um, no, five days in a row on a
very aggressive cut was a little bit
much.
I'm going to try this. I think that this
is getting rejected anyways.
Uh, if I don't see a big a big
difference from this, we're just going
to reject all of this.
I think we do potentially want
these muon improvements.
Yeah, see it doesn't need this
rescaled weight updates to have unit
variance per parameter.
Okay, that thing is dumb. We'll just do
this.
We've also ended up making some pretty
sizable breakthroughs
um in the last few days.
Research side has been going amazingly
well.
Okay, there we go.
Wait.
Okay, we might have something here.
I have to figure out what color means by
not required because that is a two
second breakout solve
You still have the problem, don't you,
Jess?
It's just under 3 seconds,
but it's still under 3 seconds.
I imagine there's probably a bit of seed
variance.
I'm still going to post the screenshot
in the Discord.
I think there might be a thing with
Muan's updates.
different transformation. Wait, what?
Help some cycle length.
Well, wait. You don't you don't
literally just do a cosine, Jess.
I don't think there's a good answer to
that particular thing, Jess.
I think this is what Aurora also
handles.
No, the new breakout solve was just me
playing with some stuff inlay. We
haven't tried the new algo on breakout
at all. I'm kind of just fiddling with a
few smaller questions at the moment.
It's not super stable though, mind you,
Finn. I'm playing with a few different
things now. I want to set a new like
stable speedrun today.
I'm going to just try I'm playing with a
couple things here.
and maybe we'll see just it's very very
difficult to figure out. I mean honestly
in some ways the language model people
have stuff way easier.
Um
like language modeling is a single much
more stable problem compared to what we
have here.
Yeah. So, this should fail horribly
because the learning rate is way too
big, right?
We live.
Stupid internet, man.
That is kind of what I always say, like,
yeah, okay, if you can do way more, but
most devs are doing negative work
anyways.
I want to see if this helps anything.
I wouldn't be surprised.
This might be worse wall clock but we
can optimize this. So the question is if
I keep same params is this stable in
fewer steps?
This should not solve right.
Yeah. So, like if I do
Yeah. So, this is where it gets volatile
because we're towards the end of the
curve.
Okay. So they have this small
improvement.
Yeah, this 100x data efficiencies thing
is [ __ ] when they have this. This is
actually the main graph here if you look
at it.
Oh,
interesting.
Yeah. No, we can't increase the learning
rate.
go check this thing. I think
Aurora
uh just like miscellaneous little
potential tweaks. Jesse.
Yeah, these are tiny little tiny little
soda.
And then wasn't this in N is the the
speedrun as well.
There's nothing to learn there though,
dude. Right.
I tried a version of that that made a
bit more sense with like a password type
end.
It's annoyingly like static Oh,
so This is interesting. This seems very
bad.
Um,
but I think that
I think we just solved this with
the orthogonalization change
that we just made.
Too few OBS. I mean, we have some M's
convert. It's going to be mazes.
Soaban 2048 and inferno.
Those are four good test
Try this on breakout as well.
possibly we'll try it on a couple other
things
We're going to also, I think, do a
little bit of this just so that we get
slightly more transferable learning
rates.
We'll try this.
Just few small improvements today. And
let me see what else I said was going to
be important.
Oops.
So, this this this.
Okay, cool. If we do all of this, then
we basically just have protein and then
this one other little weird bug.
That's [ __ ] hilarious.
That's not how it works, my friend.
Analyzing 400 million chess games should
take like
We're going to let it do this and we're
going to test it and then we're going to
[ __ ] with
What's this rectangular beta?
We're not adding hypers with this [ __ ]
If it adds hypers, we're going to delete
them. Don't worry. I just basically want
to see if this thing is roughly stable
under same hypers first
and then uh we'll figure out from there.
Yeah, crit. I want like better tested M
though for this. I want M's where we
have like more data, more experimental
data. And we have a lot of experimental
data on mazes. We've got a good amount
of experimental data on Soabon. We've
got a ton on 2048 and based on Volo's
stuff, we have quite a bit on Inferno.
When are you getting back? I'm here for
the summer, man. I don't spend the whole
year in uh on the farm.
I spend some time in Maryland. I I'm
spend some time in California. I spent
some time in Florida.
I think we're going to comment this and
try the polar real quick.
I think this is still going to be
screwy.
Yeah, I thought that as well. It's not
actually nor it's neuron wise
normalized. So, it's a really [ __ ]
stupid name,
but whatever.
Okay, that restores mostly
earthf
Did this take a bite out of perf? It did
a little bit.
I don't ever want my search engine to
give me a popup about AI mode. [ __ ] off,
Google.
never got Aurora to work at reasonable
speeds. Yeah. So, here's the thing,
Volo. Um, Aurora is aimed at non-square
matrices.
The only we have, uh, the embedding
layer is non-square. That's not a huge
deal. The big one is that we have the
projections
um in mining. They're H to three * H.
But you know actually we shouldn't be
trying to treat them as that shape
anyways. They should be treating being
treated as three separate orthogonal
matrices.
So
I'm just trying to take little bits out
that I'm pretty confident should work.
Sure thing, Jess,
if you feel like helping with that. I
honestly I got sick of banning them
because it shouldn't be my job to have
to go banan people 10 times a day
because Twitch can't moderate like the
most obvious spam ever.
There
should be good
like, you know, why should I have to be
distracted
constantly because Twitch can't do basic
basic spam filtering?
I think that is better.
So now if we do like 80 ml we definitely
solve right.
Or this could just be the
orthogonalization
uh price that we've paid.
I wonder if we can make it faster for
square mats.
What the [ __ ] did it do?
Why did it do this?
Okay,
that's fine.
few small optimizer improvements is
fine.
How fast do you think it you can get it
working?
Uh, I mean, I think you could easily
have some reasonable stuff in a day or
two of work.
At least against scripted policies, for
sure.
paper. What paper is that? Give me the
name.
Yeah, I saw that. Um,
okay. So, polar is better here.
Let's try muon polar zero.
I just want to try this with a couple
seeds cuz polar is supposed to just be
consistently better.
Okay, I think I'm happy with this as
being a very small change that's likely
correct.
uh random or inverted spectra.
Okay, this doesn't see we that doesn't
seem to matter.
idiot AI.
This was on X.
No, we don't want to compromise the
polar quality, I don't think.
Oh, I forgot to reply to Jess. Um,
well, it depends how fast the scripted
policies are, right? Like you should be
able to get 10 mil plus easily with a
very small policy and then it just
depends on the optimal policy size for
the problem.
This is a completely reasonable thing to
do.
Like that's a completely reasonable
thing to do.
That's super funny. They have way too
much money for sponsorships now, though.
That's funny as hell.
Uh, what do we got here? Uh, hypershift.
Uh,
What are the CUDA
live ones?
I don't have any, man. There really
aren't that many people streaming like
deep technical dev.
Um,
I can go over what I'm doing at the
moment. So, I basically they're just
like a variety of medium confidence
uh small like optimizer side tweaks that
we can make. Um, and
obviously validating that type of stuff
extensively is quite difficult, but
there are a few of them that are almost
certainly probably like almost certainly
good.
So, a few changes to how we're
orthogonalizing our parameters
in uh Muan. We currently have these
projections that are H to 3 H that we're
treating as one matrix instead of three.
That's bad. There's a slightly higher
quality orthogonalization algorithm that
we can integrate that's pretty much
shown to always help and it's almost
free. Um,
Oh, yeah. We were messing with warm-up,
but warm-up doesn't really seem to be
necessary or help.
Uh, we were messing with the Aurora
corrections. We realized we don't need
it as much as we thought. We did shift
our learning rates. So, I want to get
MUP in.
implementing I'm not implementing all
the papers like that would be way too
much complexity and most of it's not
really necessary for this. Um
I want to get us like a few
conveniences. is I'm going to try to get
us like more stable
uh consistent learning rate parameter.
I'm going to try to get us like slightly
more stable orthogonalization in the
optimizer
and a few other small things.
And I think collectively this will give
us you know a easy small boost to
puffer.
This is just something I haven't had
time to do. And like many of these
things were released relatively recently
and uh I just haven't had time to go
through and apply them in a reasonable
Okay.
We can check that, can't we?
861.
I mean, my general take on the models at
the moment is they've gotten better.
They work if you were using them heavily
a year ago. It's just because you're a
terrible programmer. Uh they've gotten
better. They're still incredibly dumb.
They make huge huge major errors. They
will make a complete disaster of your
codebase if you just let them do
whatever. But like they are useful tools
and I use them in a I would like to say
more limited and controlled way compared
to what you will see people doing.
uh Okay. Okay. Well, that's a complete
disaster.
Yeah. I You know what was really funny?
I saw an ex um earlier today. Somebody
implemented like a bit internet man.
I can't tell if that's the internet
blipping or if it's reream. H.
Um yeah, I saw that uh somebody like
went to implement their own rendering
library and just full vibe coded and
they ended up ripping off Rayb so badly
that it was identical API like literally
identical and they even copied the color
constant names of Ray White and stuff.
But I'm sure they thought, "Wow, look, I
just implemented a whole rendering
library with the LM, but literally just
copied Rayb into Typescript.
Well, it is the worst thing to copy in
the sense that it's already perfectly
well-built and your shitty vibecoded
version is just going to be way worse.
and then I think we can merge some of
these things after.
mystic in a match in a magic short vow
2.1 times.
Okay. Okay. So it trains with bigger
hidden policy
So, we'll see. This is supposed to fail.
Um, we'll see if it does.
Okay, cool. I can confirm we get much
better.
This is absolutely, by the way, watch me
bumble through optimizer crap. Um, I
have a vague understanding of what is
going on here enough to not be being
like completely stupid, but there's
still going to be quite a bit of stupid
stuff here. Um, I am pretty confident I
can do this well enough to not make any
major mistakes as provided I ask a bunch
of dumb questions and like sanity check
things repeatedly.
I think it is stable enough.
smart enough to No, I'm smart enough to
mostly avoid the LMBBS and at least
catch it downstream quickly most of the
time.
Mention dependent magnitude. Those are
compatible.
Okay. So, I think we just have to make
sure they stack them
correctly.
Um,
the profile script I think should unless
I broke it yesterday.
I might not have pushed everything cuz I
was messing with that.
There is no more I think. Is there a
d-profile thing still? I I forget. We do
have a profile script that gives you all
the Turk kernel timings and stuff.
same scale as original. So, did we end
up the same [ __ ]
original full matrix scaling and perize
MUI. Okay.
Okay, so we basically end up at the
original thing. We kind of get lucky
that when we do the per slice version,
um, we get we we basically get the Mui
roll.
New Allstar season.
That's fun.
Oh, yeah. Uh, I can show you one cool
little thing.
Evalo
Honestly, the only thing that was
annoying is I had to do about 3 hours of
agility.
Because the um the hunter relic solves
um the hunter relic solves
uh 99 hunter not terribly
and uh it solves
basically the uh the 50 mil fire making
as well.
Doesn't the decoder need this?
I think the decoder needs this as well.
Oh yeah, Val, I think I actually got all
of the optimal relic choices for my
regions.
I think I did it pretty well.
And um I'll be finishing it at rune
tier. It's not worth my um well I'm not
going to put in the time to get dragon.
Um but hey, I'll finish it rune which is
cool.
I mean that's just like an absurd amount
of time grinding boring [ __ ] anyways.
Oh, okay. Cool. This looks like this
actually helps.
Yeah. So look, now we have the same
learning rate. We solve with 1024
and we should solve
if I go to 64 as well.
Yeah, we solve at 64 pretty well.
Cool.
does does.
Okay, it currently already does
Okay. So, this is this is now good, I
would say.
Um, I can at least can I put this down
to 90 mil or 85 mil.
This is nice and consistent.
Why are you not sweeping here? I'm doing
quick checks, Volo. These are just quick
checks.
So all I've done is I've added two very
high confidence things, right? So I've
added there's a learning rate scale that
should just basically bring everything
up to the same scale regardless of
hidden size. Um it's pretty much just
equivalent to tuning by I think it's
like one over square root or whatever of
the hidden size. Um and then there is
one additional thing that we have
which is
oh yeah the polar uh the polar
orthogonalization that should just be
like a slight numerical win and then
there was one thing that we were just
orthogonalizing wrong but that's
basically
it's not really a bug fix as much as
it's like a better mathematical model.
So, we're orthogonalizing the correct
thing. And then that also makes us
immune to um most of this stuff Aurora
is trying to do. Anyways,
I don't know. Do we need the Aurora
correction for um
for linear layers?
And then the one other thing I wanted to
try was theuler.
And then we'll basically take all this
crap chuck it on um a couple problems
that are actually tough and we'll see if
they work.
This is the thing that actually Jess was
asking for. Stopping time steps in
advance. Yeah.
Okay.
That would actually be a major upgrade.
This is still good and stable.
Wait, are we at 17 mil? Is that a thing?
No, that's Eval. Okay, we're good.
And we just do policy hidden size.
This works.
Where are my bookmarks?
Okay, this is the schedule free guy.
We're stable at 80 mil now mostly. Let's
say seed five.
Yeah, this is stable at 80 mil. We just
shaved some uh some steps off the
optimizer. Very nice.
And then this schedule three thing is
going to be the next thing we look at.
This would be really good. Like this
shitty disc schedule is such a pain in
the ass.
I'm going to use the restroom real
quick.
Um, actually, this is a good time for me
to take a short break
uh in order to grab my vitamins and
stuff and get myself uh coffee.
Let me just make sure that this is set
up. Oh, yeah. This is a great time to
remind folks if you're new around here,
I stream all my research right here. Um,
if you want to help me out for
absolutely free, just start puffer on
GitHub. Like, it's that easy. really
really helps
cuz we do a lot of professional work as
well and um when this number goes up
people message me and I don't have to
spend my time advertising meaning I get
to spend my time here doing live R&D
you can also join Discord if you want to
get involved with this development
effort a lot of it is much easier than
you'd expect like all these environments
super useful for research mostly by
contributors you can also follow me on X
for more RL content including all my
educational stuff. Let me make sure that
this still works.
We're going to obviously go through all
this stuff
today.
Wait, did it get rid of the right thing?
Yes. Yes, it did. We're good.
So then that is basically slight
difference to learning rate scaling um
slight difference to uh rather the
update scaling for moopy. So now we have
much more consistent learning crates
across model sizes. Uh slightly better
orthogonalization method and then much
much more correct way that we are
applying orthogonalization
uh with the way that our encoder layers
work because our encoders have h to
three times h dim but it's really three
separate map moles that we're just
sticking together for the efficiency.
So, this will be much better.
No, I'm not leaving early. I'm just
going to go grab myself a coffee and get
my vitamins and take a few minutes. And
uh, you know, stream's been doing
decently well. We typically are
somewhere between 10 and 20 people
across uh, YouTube and Twitch. I don't
know about X, actually, cuz X never
shows the exact count.
Make sure we didn't break it. And then
we'll do schedule. Well, actually just
the next thing we're going to try is
schedule free, which would fix the
cosine enaling problem. Be very cool.
So that would give you the same learning
curve. And then if you just run it
longer, it should just be better.
And of course, we deleted this argument.
Okay, we'll do this next. Be right back,
guys.
Hey. Hey, this will what?
What is all these people all of a
sudden?
Okay, next thing we're going to do.
Oh, for [ __ ] sake. No damn coin.
People out. Get out. Serious research.
Jesus Christ. I This happens like every
few months. Stop. Stop using my name for
coins. Stop. There are other people
you're gonna get with this. I'm not one
of them.
All right.
We charge six figures plus for our
contracts.
You're not going to get me interested in
whatever shilling coin thing. Back to
research.
All right. So, this is what's actually
happening in this stream. So, um at the
moment, we have just integrated a few
tweaks from Keller's.
So, if you've seen this thing, this is
an awesome piece of research.
Um, now a lot of the modifications
towards the end here have been like very
specific minor things,
but we got um we got a few of the muon
improvements from here.
We did this, but then we integrated MUP,
which actually, funny enough, gets you
very close back to where you started.
Um, but we did make one important
change. So now you pretty much should
not have to retune learning rate just
because of changing model size. This
should also make it easier for protein
to learn.
Uh we don't have warm up or anything
else. We don't need that.
Um
and the next thing so with this this was
pretty good on its own. We also
integrated this is a really good blog
post.
I highly recommend this.
This is the Aurora optimizer. It finds a
bug in Muon and patches it. Essentially,
I figured out that the thing that this
thing is trying to patch
algorithmically,
it actually only applies to our
embedding layer. So, we applied this
there, but the rest of our layers, they
go from H to 3H, which would be affected
by the Muon bug, but actually our layers
are three matrix projections. It's kind
of like the QK uh QKV
from uh transformer but for a totally
different purpose. We can just split
those and do the orthogonalization
separate and then we don't have to deal
with it. So we only have this for the
embedding layer which is super nice. Uh
and then a couple other small things and
now we've got some pretty consistent
results. Only 80 million steps, 4
seconds for breakout. It's quite nice.
And then the next thing we're going to
do here, so Jess, this is the thing that
you've been requesting and actually this
has been a pain in the ass for a long
time. Um, so the idea is that having to
have a learning rate scheduler makes it
very hard to scale your experiments
because you're essentially messing the
your learning rate will actually change.
Let's say that you run a 10 billstep
run, okay? uh the learning rate that you
use at say four million time steps in
that run will not be the same as if you
do the same experiment for 100 billion
because of theuler and that screws up
hyperparameter transfer very badly. So
we're going to try this for that. I'm
going to start reading this at the same
time that I just give it here.
Oh uh actually remove while here. Okay,
next thing you
going to try.
Boom. There we go.
And now we actually read.
There should be no yolo training runs.
All right. This guy rocks. Yo. Okay.
This guy rocks.
Does Twitch have mod?
Twitch doesn't have [ __ ] mod.
Yeah, dropping pumpf fun links in my
chat is insta banan
and all your alts as well.
Yeah. And if any of my real viewers were
curious, I'm not affiliated with any of
this stuff. They're trying to steal your
money. So,
Inner momentum into schedule free fixes
large batch training divergence.
Ooh.
Uh that actually is interesting. I don't
know about this problem.
Okay, warm-up still usually is,
but then Muan doesn't is supposed to not
need this.
Okay, we need the large batch changes as
well.
Wait. Well, eval checkpoint uses X. Roll
out train uses Y.
Wait, explain. I need this API
difference. Um,
wait. Actually, I can just click this,
can't I?
takes the current loss as a scaler
instead of a closure.
Huh? You don't need the closure.
Okay, normally there's one parameter
vector you compute gradients
optimizer updates and you evaluate and
checkpoint
schedule free has
raw optimizer iterate averaged iterate
iterate weight used to compute the next
gradient.
The next gradient is computed at yt.xt.
Evaluation checkpoint final mode should
use x.
save the eval waits
checkpoint.
We'll try this first and then we'll see
what the hell's we'll see if this makes
any sense.
This has to be able to at least match on
breakout for me to want to be able to
like mess with this. Um so this adds
this adds one hyperparameter I believe
but I think that's worth it for deleting
cosine and kneeling
and all our other analing things have
not really mattered that
It's a little irritating though. All
these LLM guys are basically training on
the same exact task, right? So they all
get to just swap hyperparameters with
each other. Whereas in our case, we have
a bunch of different problems and
nobody's doing the same problem.
I think this is relatively promising.
It's got an endorsement from Lucas as
well.
I mean, if if all of these work today,
then this is basically
Let's say that we don't get the uh the
learning rate free stuff. All right. Um
but let's say that we get the decay
schedule free.
So, we have a learning rate that we
tune, but we don't have to have a
schedule on it. Um that would mean way
better transfer of hypers to longer
runs. And then from the other stuff that
we did earlier today or just before
this, we also should get substantially
better
um hyperparameter or learning rate
scaling to larger networks. If you
change the model size, the piper should
stay way way way more the same.
And you should also just get a nice
stability boost overall from the
orthogonalization changes. So you know
several small things that together would
be a quite meaningful improvement.
Now all this stuff is going to add a
little bit of overhead to the algorithm
but uh we will iterate on our kernels
and stuff to
uh get around that.
Yeah, like look blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah too much code, right? Way way
way too much code.
of puffer six. No, we'll see what's in
puffer six.
I think that I want to have like very
very stable.
If by puffer five we have very stable
everything and pretty much the remaining
problems are like clean and well
defined, then puffer six will aim to
solve the remaining ones.
So I think puffer six is like RL is
stable mature field that works in my
mind.
In case it wasn't obvious, this is way
way way too me too much codeex usage.
Uh the only reason I'm doing this is to
quickly explore all these things to see
if they even work and then if they do
work like this is all tech debt that
this is not going into the update,
right? like this is going to be manually
cleaned up dramatically.
Yeah, better get your contracts in by
puffer 7. By puffer 7, we charge seven
figures.
Now, realistically, by Puffer 7, we'll
probably be um looking for some very
large applications that we can just take
on
internally in Puffer.
I think we'll actually even like puffer
five will even just let the python still
be in it.
Probably puffer six will be no python.
Yeah, I think that's probably the case,
Jess. Like puffer. So if puffer um I
think puffer five will be a quick update
internet.
Are we alive?
Okay, we're alive. Um
yeah, so puffer five is going to So
puffer
four was a very long update. Um puffer
five is going to be a very short update.
Buffer six will probably be
somewhere in the middle
and then seven will likely be like an
applied problem.
Maybe even six will be applied. Who
knows?
learning rate and schedule free. Yeah,
we just need the schedule free part. We
don't really need the learning rate free
part. Cutting one hyperparameter is not
that valuable to us.
Well, I said that there wasn't like any
obvious simple solution to it. Like,
it's this guy's whole research.
I honestly forgot that this even
existed. And last time I tried it, it
didn't work very well. But apparently,
I'm a little bit late on this because
apparently this has been out for like a
year plus and been kind of good.
right. Nothing's worth it here now.
We're just Let's focus on dev for the
next little bit. Close.
Close
Ah, here you go.
This is nice.
Tim's got boxabon at 10 at a 20 mil SPS.
Very nice.
Schedule free beta.
Schedule free R.
What was this um this beta that they
gave
beta 0.8 8 to 0.95
965.
Could just be the parameters, could be
the implementation, could be many
things.
much higher for the number of updates we
do.
Maybe the learning rate needs to be
retuned.
Huh?
They need massive massive learning right
now or something.
No.
What gives?
If we could get this to work, it would
be very, very nice.
I want to see if we can match coine and
nailing with this thing.
We have more on this paper on um
Twitter. Oops.
N there's nothing on this.
Maybe some of his earlier stuff.
This is for weight decay. We don't care
about this.
What is that? Not just from the Dota
paper. Is that a different thing? chess.
Oh,
wait. But Alpha Star has the whole
leagues [ __ ]
I'm just looking for this guy's earlier
stuff on um
on schedule free if he's put anything.
weighted sampling of historical
opponent.
All right,
that could be reasonable.
I am hoping that we get some simple
thing based on historical selfplay to
work cuz like leagues is
league sampling gets to be a pain in the
ass.
Yeah. Let's see if this warm-up was the
problem.
Well, he'll try it, Jess. I mean, I'm
actively discussing like the the
selfplay experiments with him. Um
because it's going to be a major
we live.
Stupid internet keeps blipping.
I hope it's not cutting the VOD
literally every time on YouTube.
Yeah. So, this is just stupid long warm
up because LM is dumb, right?
What am I doing today? Um, this is
Oh, hang on. This actually works.
on. Let me finish this thought real
quick.
I'll explain in one second. Let me
finish this tuning real
Okay. So, what I'm doing at the moment
is a bunch of miscellaneous optimizer
training whatever improvements. These
are mostly like small algorithmic tweaks
um that have been developed fairly
recently and I'm kind of just
aggregating the ones that are the
highest likelihood of improving things
testing as best as I can only taking
stuff from the good from good sources
not really doing anything that's like
maybe works but not really uh so far we
have made one clear mathematical fix to
our orthogonalization inside muon
We've made one clear improvement to our
orthogonalization
numerical method, our algorithm for that
in Muan. Um, we have made one uh small
tweak that allows us to have much more
consistent learning rate across model
sizes based on MUP. We added one
slightly more speculative thing that
changes uh the waiting of encoder
updates a little bit.
And uh now we are working on this
schedule free algorithm to see if we can
replace cosine analing which would give
us much more consistent performance from
shorter to longer runs with the same
hyperparameters. There's
Just checking if our optimal like
learning rate changed because of this
method or something.
Nope. Bigger and smaller are both worse.
We'll trust our original uh learning
rate.
0.8 8 annealed to 0.965.
Wait, you still are annealing the
[ __ ] beta value, man.
How can you possibly say that schedule
free if you're scheduling your own beta
value?
What's the point if you're still
scheduling the thing?
Yeah, he has a [ __ ] schedule in the
schedule fray.
Maybe the learning rate just shifted a
little bit.
Oh, it's very unstable is the thing
here.
I wouldn't be surprised if I do 100 if
it solves.
Doesn't even solve in 100 though.
That's quite bad.
Unless this is now like way bigger
because
try this real quick.
It'd be great if this works. How much
time am I going to spend on this? Half
hour more, maybe
we conclude this is just like not
as advertised.
Okay, sure.
Try that. But I doubt this. I highly
highly doubt this does anything.
It's probably something like this.
I'm basically just trying um just to
make sure like the hypers didn't shift.
I'm basically not going to put the
effort into fully doing this stuff until
I have um
some reasonable evidence
because
So the thing that this solves for us um
for our longer experiments
it's really irritating that we tune
parameters say to like 500 million steps
and then they don't work when we run for
10 billion steps because the cosine and
nailing totally messes with the learning
rate in a different Okay.
[ __ ] [ __ ] I swear.
And then they block you so you actually
can't reply to tell it to say that it's
a scam is the funny part with that.
Yeah, this doesn't work cuz this [ __ ]
takes for [ __ ] ever. They need to
expedite this crap
if they want to be changing [ __ ]
This keeps coming fine. I guess
I mean we'll try I guess you know what
I'm down to do I'm down to just like
throw crap at wall for a bit and uh if
it doesn't work we'll just remove
schedule free and we will go back to uh
our nice thing from Four.
Let's also go to our default learning
rate.
Uh [ __ ] Did this like massively
increase the optimal learning rate?
Yeah.
Hang on. Let me see if it's one.
No. Okay. Is it somewhere in between?
Still don't think this is enough.
Actually, it's not. It's supposed to be
0.1.
You see,
cuz there's an ablation on this, isn't
there?
Yeah, this varies pretty massively,
doesn't it? One over L1.
Do they have the um the graph that you
would actually want in this paper which
is
learning over more steps?
again. We're just throwing [ __ ] at this.
This probably if this doesn't work, this
is all getting cut anyways.
Okay, here we'll have a couple things to
try.
For context, this has become less of an
educated guess now and more of a I don't
[ __ ] know, throw [ __ ] at it, see if
it works.
Um, I would not be surprised at this
point if this is like overfit to LLMs.
if this does work. It will be very, very
nice.
We don't absolutely need it, but it
would be very nice.
What is this? Why is it like this?
Right.
See, this is the type of thing I would
catch if I were paying attention.
This should learn something now, right?
If it learns nothing, it's a bug. If it
learns like okayish,
maybe it's just not super great, you
know?
Cuz I don't believe this just doesn't
learn.
Nope. Not that.
So,
I mean, the thing I could only think of
is that this is just not made for Muan.
Uh, okay. Wait, we didn't need P. Okay,
hang on.
Not the whole time, Jess.
Last 10 minutes.
Okay. Okay. So, this is just supposed to
be the schedule
And that's supposed to be for long runs.
That doesn't help.
We can try the warm up here to a bigger
LR, but I don't think this is good.
This is not good. See?
So, it did stupid. Cool.
We'll try a few more things because of
everything I've messed up here.
It's a very odd change, honestly. Okay.
It's not like just swapping in cosine
and kneeling.
Wait, but then two does.
Is this just noise?
If we assume that Muan doesn't need the
warm up.
Ah, okay.
Now we're getting somewhere. If we
assume Muan doesn't need the warm up.
So it doesn't work without warming up.
Um
see
Isn't it supposed to just get better now
if I do it like this?
Um, it's in dev. It's quite messy. It's
been in development just for the last
like week or so. It's going to be a
quite short update, but I will have
something stable hopefully uh in a
couple hours.
I'm mostly just deciding what we're
going to do with this schedule free
stuff and if I there's any reasonable
form of this.
Yeah, it messes up if you don't nail the
beta.
We had it very consistent without this,
right?
Like just to kind of show you how fiddly
this is.
I'm going to give this until 3 p.m. and
then we're going to drop this is too
fiddly
unfortunately.
And then if anybody else wants to do
this as a project, they can feel free.
We also shouldn't need 95.
What's the project? This is schedule
free. Uh this is nice because in theory
this should at least uh this should help
for very long experiments.
I mean I would categorize this one as
quite advanced.
It's not even Vim. It's like something
is just [ __ ] up my terminal and
deleting the top of files when I open
it. It's the most obnoxious [ __ ]
I didn't catch it that time, so I just
saved the file.
This is close now. This is this is
actually close now.
Long weekend to get some RNR, go for
some runs, and we'll see from there.
I honestly wouldn't be surprised if this
[ __ ] just doesn't [ __ ] work. Um,
I mean, this is the problem with
language modeling research. They
literally have one problem. It's the
same problem. It's super stable. It
barely changes based on your data. Like
compared to RL,
they've got all the stability in the
This doesn't I mean the schedulers
aren't going to help in the sense that
like we'll still have the stupid
mismatch.
Yep. This this makes fundamentally zero
[ __ ] sense for RL. Um,
that makes absolutely zero [ __ ] sense
for RL. So, this thing's got brain
damage because uh I guess it's supposed
to like shove some like pretty hard math
theorems or something, but this is
pretty [ __ ] stupid.
So,
I've played with this thing for three
hours. This thing feels awful. Uh,
horribly unstable. Uh, I'm done messing
with this for now. If anybody else wants
to mess with this, by all means. I don't
think this approach actually makes sense
because
it's requiring you normally to run
inference with a different set of
weights from training.
And in RL that means you just don't see
uh you just don't see the portions of
the N that you should like you're not
allowed to have a PF gap between your
weights. That's not a thing that makes
sense in RL.
buy
first one
that real quick.
And um
Uh, okay. I think it broke itself.
Did I hit a Did I hit a key?
That is a perfect summary of today.
Uh-huh.
Yeah, I think we're just not going to
deal with this. Thank you.
I I actually don't want to keep this cuz
I think it's like completely [ __ ]
itself. So,
let's just
Yeah, we'll get ourselves a minimal
diff.
It will work soon if anybody wants to
try it. I'm not spending any more time
on this. Um, this does not feel
directionally correct.
I generally do not spend my time like
trying to force a thing that feels super
brittle and janky to work.
That's not something I want to introduce
into Puffer. If anybody gets a version
of schedule free working that's actually
like stable, consistent, works across
seeds, um you know, you run it for more
time steps and it just kind of just does
a little better but does keeps the same
curves in the early part. Like that's
all good.
This is a nice post.
It's actually a very nice post.
Cool.
That's a that's a very nice post.
May the solver be applied to net hack.
You'd need state sets. So net hack you'd
have to edit the source code quite a
bit.
Uh it seems like the approach should
help though. We still have to run quite
a bunch of experiments on it.
knew about the problem trying it a few
hours. Not really. And this is why I
typically don't pull like random [ __ ]
off of Twitter because most of the time
you go and try it and it doesn't [ __ ]
work. Um,
Keller's stuff has been quite
consistently good, I would say.
But like,
yeah, the LLM
LLM people are just kind of
rediscovering
what happens when you have one problem
and you try to do general work on one
problem.
I guess the exception is well, it should
be the optimizer work, but I think that
the schedulers touch too many other
things, not just the optimizer.
Okay, give it all this crap.
Basically, what I'm going to do is I'm
going to get this thing down to a very
minimal diff and then PR and then we're
like clean it up.
But yeah, like look at all these
parameters we're getting rid of.
Bunch of garbage.
We will also be able to get rid of uh we
will be able to get rid of the beta 2
param. That one is dead.
And I believe there is also an epsilon
parameter
that we can move.
Oh yeah. What's the current decay in
nano GPT? Okay.
Definitely there's other stuff we could
do. Like I probably shouldn't have spent
so long on this except I really wanted
to have um the better long experiment
transfer.
There's all sorts of other stuff I could
be doing.
where was the last like big improvement
made actually
LR decay to 0.1 instead of zero.
That's nice.
What are we working on now? Cleaning up
the PR.
uh it contains several things. It
contains orthogonalization
uh better numerical orthogonalization
method more correct application of
orthogonalization for mining group
layers. It contains uh better scaling
for the encoder layers. Um and then it
also contains this MUP like update that
should make the learning rate much more
stable over large uh over a range of
model sizes.
Uh MUP was already almost integrated. We
just needed a couple very small tweaks.
This also should not change I think this
should not change the um
the learning rates or the hyper
parameters required.
We will see. But I think we should be
fine.
Uh, it just makes it easier to tune.
It just makes it easier to tune because
um the learning rates preserved. It's
just a scaling factor.
So yeah, this one does not actually just
transfer.
What's the problem spec
right now? It's just a lot of very small
improvements that add up nicely
for Puffer.
nice. It replaced it in all the config
files for me without me having to ask.
We're going to have to do uh we're going
to have to clean this up to commit it,
but it' be a pretty minimal diff.
That's better.
We might need um
85 mil.
I do kind of wonder what happens if we
use
params for mazes.
Why don't we go grab?
No. Why don't we just go grab real
quick?
[ __ ] Yo, let me copy
copy this parameter. Yeah,
there we go.
Delete everything down to sweep.
Oh, and then did we we did sweep this,
right?
Yeah, we did sweep this. Cool.
Jeez,
taking a while.
Okay,
that's not bad.
We'll just leave this here.
Uh, I'll be right back. Let me use a
restroom real quick.
So, um we'll see how this goes. The hope
is that this is at least on par with
perf from before. Hopefully a little
better.
It's a nice configuration.
Whole bunch of steps it runs. Decent
little net.
Okay. Anything
else we can pull in from
pillar?
I don't think there's anything super
great otherwise in here.
Tuned learning rate.
So, Muan is the first really big
improvement Here.
Not really.
The nano GPT baseline's pretty good.
What's this? Ru squared.
Oh, it's just the same loss, but it's
faster to calculate. I see.
Where's uh where'd it go?
Where'd it go?
Funny. Upgrade torch. That's like a nice
endorsement of torch, I suppose.
Worth the whole thing to cuda down to
one minute
I think that's basically the last
big thing.
Okay, so this was the uh the flex
attention thing.
Big flex attention thing. Cool.
Uh where is it?
unit.
404.
Where's the unit?
What's this?
God damn it. Geeks for geeks.
Oh,
well that's not going to be relevant
now, is it?
Yeah, this is the last big one,
honestly.
So
value residual
value residual with learnable lambda
embed shortcut
momentum warm-up and tang logic
clipping. It's most of it's mostly this
value residual learning.
This is actually very close to a highway
connection.
Yeah, I don't know, Jess. It's a
specific architecture, not
super useful to us. Okay, so there might
be something we can do with a residual
structure of some type.
I think that's the last like major
potential even thing in here, though.
Um,
yeah, most of it's just from padding the
embeddings. That's funny.
I had removed it for no good reason.
That's funny.
I met him in SFJ.
He seemed cool.
Power two. Yeah.
How's this going?
All right. We're at five 6K.
5K.
If it does way worse, I'm going to get
concerned. But if it's within ballpark,
I hope it's reasonable.
Okay. So, I think this is a nice little
set of changes. I mean, the only other
thing that we even have to do in puffer
uh four on that side is this one PR
It always takes the argmax which gets
stuck at the boundaries.
Hang on,
Okay, I have
arg max of the scores.
And then what's this one?
Zero genetics. So this is in always
takes the argmax over scores.
So presumably,
no, he still has Argax in here.
His comments don't make sense to me, but
let me see.
This is definitely some claw because
it's just deleting all my [ __ ]
comments.
So what?
He replaced our colonel
he basically deletes
one of our pruning heristics. X.
This is also not understanding our
thing.
I'm gonna have to just go run this thing
on um
on like breakout and a couple of M's
because some of these things seem very
weird to There.
Yeah. So, we also intentionally didn't
do this because
it's super sketchy with the way that RL
um outputs are
I don't actually remember what the hell
that is.
Yeah.
But why?
Been a while. Was there 6k when you had
two? Oh, welcome. I just keep going on
the research agenda here. Hh.
I'm so confused by what this PR is,
though.
I mean, I'm gonna just have to try this.
Like,
he says this is better. I have no idea
what the [ __ ]
I'll probably have to spend a few days
next week on this.
See, I don't understand why he thinks
this is a bad thing.
That shouldn't result in
converging to boundaries.
this adds quite a bit of complexity
actually because it looks like this is
about a same size PR, but he's deleted
all of the comments.
More likely Claude has.
We will try this though.
Or rather the uh the company is the
library is free.
I'm afraid this is going to end up a
little worse. We'll see.
But what is the um
what's this trade-off look like?
No, actually this curve
this curve is kind of nice, isn't it?
Like if I put this in linear.
Yeah, this is kind of nice, right? You
just spend
you spend more compute, it does better.
Actually, look at this. So this actually
looks like,
okay, we can put this being worse at low
scale down to bad tuning, but it looks
like this is actually scaling better
with compute than before.
Yeah, we do RL projects or company for
companies basically.
We build high performance sims. We
integrate stuff with Puffer.
Now, most people just cloning the
project don't have a decade of RL
experience as well as the experience of
having built the library itself.
I actually think that this is possibly
Yeah, when you look at it this way, this
is quite solid.
Now, the question is, did I mess it up
in uh in the latest commit?
We're seeing the 16K on there
occasionally,
but I suppose we will see.
One moment. I'll be right back.
All right.
Is this Windows cmd?
Well, I'm sshed into Linux boxes. I just
This is an old machine that happened to
still have Windows on it.
Okay, so I managed to lose a little bit
of PF. Um,
I will have to rerun the sweep on this.
go to here.
It's still better than uh previous Is it
better than previous soda?
Hang on. How much perf did we lose?
There could still be some variability in
there.
Uh, all of our all of my stuff is on
policy. We found last summer that off
policy just straight doesn't work.
Um,
so this is Puffer Libs Hyperf custom
algorithm. It's on policy or at least
it's on policy as PO normally is.
What I did today was I did some nice
optimizer improvements.
Uh, just some like very small but
important math fixes on the way that we
do orthogonalization, how we apply it, a
few other small things like that.
We're going to rerun some hyperparameter
sweeps based on this.
Um, we've also got protein to mess with,
which is the sweep algorithm itself.
So, I think I'm just going to set two
boxes up worth of sweeps right now.
Okay, we can get that
learning is just so the problem with off
policy methods is that they don't scale
nicely with compute. Um it's not like oh
you can do as well as on policy and then
spend a little bit more compute and do
better. It's like you spend a massive
amount of compute to do as well as on
policy, if you even can, and then you
spend a massive amount of additional
compute to try to do a little better
because you didn't want to run your
simulator for a few more steps.
So, Jess, uh, as for what improvements,
I have no idea. I have a big PR. Uh, I
don't understand what the hell it is.
It's by somebody who is good. Uh, and he
says that it is much better than protein
on the stuff he has tested. So,
I'm going to probably
overnight I'm going to run a baseline
with the current breakout
and then I'm also going to run 2048
again
and then after that we will see.
Yeah, I know. Jonas PR Jonas PR is
kernels and infrastructure. Kernels and
infrastructure are part of 50, but like
the first two weeks are not about that.
The first two weeks are about like
getting all of the algorithmic changes
in.
That'll be it.
This can be cleaned up, but this is
actually not bad.
Uh yes, we have a few people in the
community that are interested in doing
stuff around that.
Yeah, like Jess here.
Okay, so this runs
Okay,
this is nice.
there.
Should be able to sweep this
Looks fine.
Okay. Get pull.
Oops. Been live six hours it looks like.
Just shy. Maybe
upper end of the comp.
Depends whether
people in Puffer want to release that
while the comp is live.
Let's also just grab the uh the
parameters if we didn't already. I think
we did get them already though. Yeah.
Know, because we already did just commit
up all the prams, we should be good.
Yeah. No, Twitch has the um the lowest
delay. YouTube has not bots.
Um and X has
the biggest audience, I guess.
Okay, we have all these runs going
nicely. We can see that here.
Seems a little bit odd to me.
I want to make sure this is actually
running correctly.
Um that is quite nice.
Now we have six runs. So this is uh this
is actually working good.
This is working.
Um so today we have
we integrated a few smaller changes.
Things should generally be fine. Um if I
wake up in the morning to a much better
breakout sweep that would be pretty
cool. I think these are going to be
pretty small changes though. Uh
integration of Polar Express
Angular collection. It's like four four
small algorithmic changes. This one's
basically guaranteed good. This one's
guaranteed good. This one's guaranteed
good. The only one that's a little
questionable is the Aurora one,
but I think that should be fine as well.
It may or may not be required,
but I think the other ones are pretty
solid. Um, hopefully we recover
the original.
I really really do like this graph
though like the more that I look at this
graph it actually it doesn't look very
good on log scale but when you put this
on linear scale this is a whole another
story right like we care about asymtoic
improvements in the algorithm
look at this
look how far this goes on the log scale
and then look how much steeper this is
here
so it seems like this scales quite a bit
better with compute and I guess for this
end of that kind of makes sense because
this should be a lot better at the end
games. This is the state set algorithm.
So I mean we'll have to see from here uh
how this does but I think it could be
quite good. I think it could be quite
good.
It is for today. I think I'm going to
end a little early for the uh the long
weekend. May or may not stream on
Monday. I think I said I would, but I
forgot it's a holiday weekend. Um, I
probably will. We'll see. We've also
made very very good time on uh on these
changes. Like pretty much the only thing
that we have to do left. So, we have to
make sure that these res like that these
changes are fine. We got to run some
more sweeps on 2048.
Um,
we have to run some sweeps on like set
up some sweeps on the other uh the other
three test M's. Really two test M. So,
not that hard at all.
I think that's it on the ALGO side.
Really,
I think that's pretty much it.
The only question is if we can have some
nice improvements to protein or not.
Um, even if we can't though,
how many hypers do we have? We did add
some more hypers.
One,
two, three. Yeah, it adds four hypers.
Quite a bit.
Yeah, it's quite a bit.
Well, we shall see.
How do I aggregate into set over the
episode?
It's not 16bit encodes. I you should
just look at the current 50 repo pepper.
Um
it's like a combination of keeping top k
highest advantage states. Uh saving
every 16 states into this buffer,
reweing the advantages every time you
get new information updates. It's not a
lot of code, but it's a pretty
complicated thing. Uh, I don't know what
that is, Pepper.
This gap is a little concerning here.
I think we just need to make some
improvements to protein though.
again just I don't have anything in mind
on the improvements. I have a big PR
that I don't understand
uh from somebody very experienced in
optimization
and I'm going to basically try it and if
it works I'll try to understand what the
hell it
We definitely need to understand stable
ranges for hypers better.
I bet you like that if we just do
I bet you if I just do something basic
like this
the learning rate optimum like is way
tighter right already
like right in there versus let's Okay.
Yeah. See, it widens with the bigger
hidden size.
I believe I'm not sweeping this one.
Yeah. So that's fine. This is a standard
breakout sweep.
And then this should be a state setbased
Yeah. State set based 2048 sweep. Good.
Okay. I think that that's basically all
I need to do. Let me make sure
this is still going.
And then this is still going. Okay,
cool. Uh, so thank you folks for tuning
in. I'm going to call it just about
here. If you'd like to support my work
for absolutely free and help me to be
spending more of my time streaming
rather than on annoying administrative
stuff, you can help get the word out
just by starring Puffer on GitHub.
If you want to get involved with
development or join the community,
Discord's right here. And other than
that, you can follow me on X for all of
my other RL content, including
educational stuff. For instance, the
blog post about this latest block of
research. That'll be there on X as well.